yes it's happening it's happening look
who's here guys it's Jenna
it's so exciting Jenna is here to record
an episode of not too deep but while
she's here I thought we would play a
game and this is called the urban
dictionary challenge it's called create
that we'll call it that a very cryptic
name what's gonna happen here is that
Jack very off-camera will read us a word
from urban dictionary and Jenna and I
are gonna write down what we think the
definition is and the one that is either
the closest to the correct definition or
has created the best definition we'll
get a point
it's a completely subjective game yes
really great do you feel confident I
mean I'm ready I'm so I feel like you're
gonna be so much better at this than I
am
well I might actually know some of these
I know that's what I live in this weird
jaded bubble where I look at a paper
mache giraffe all day so I have no idea
what anything means I read urban
dictionary just in my free time first of
five will be considered the winner the
first word is Marg rain okay I'm done
I'm done doing time do you want to go
first yeah okay Mar Green when you get a
migraine headache from being around
Margaret ah that sounds like that's
probably the right answer I said it's a
noun it's Catholic toast I don't know
why but something that Graeme everything
of chose and more like Mary I don't know
it is the brain freeze caused by rapidly
slurping down a frozen margarita
beverage yeah I feel like the points
gotta go to Jenna yes yes margrave's
begs is the next word is nomophobia Noma
phobia nomophobia Jenna what do you have
Noma phobia the fear of having no mo of
something oh that's really good
I took me a second I said when you're
afraid of not being homophobic according
to urban dictionary nomophobia means the
fear of being away from a mobile phone
no mo no mobile yeah I mean yeah I
really feel like Jenna's like also like
being afraid of being away from your
trailer home like no mo oh yeah no mo ok
Jenna's got two points y'all let's just
do this dot watching mmm
dot watching not watching not watching
oh okay well I'm so bad at like spelling
bees and anything that had to do is I'm
finding anything with words dot watching
watching someone twerking and polka dot
underwear dot watching I'm off for that
that's a club I would join I said when
you watch the dot of your uber driver
arriving all the time I just watch I
watch it and then I watch them shop and
go the wrong way and then I wait to see
if they're gonna call let me know you're
going the wrong way wrong way wrong way
wrong way jump off your door like in
Titanic and blow the whistle it is the
desperately intense observation of your
smartphone screen message thread as you
wait in hope for a reply from someone
you are romantically engaged am Gredos
3des I have you romantically involved
with so many uber drivers control you
know that there's a Jif of those three
dots that people send now over text
message yeah sister sent this yeah he
sends them to everyone so you think that
someone's with that texting you
yeah do I get a point yes that's the
point Narcis X well okay I have someone
turned on by the self-centeredness of
someone else and or often pronounced
narco sexual and someone turned on by
narcs but either one I said that a
narcissus you love having sex with a
cardboard cutout of your
a weird hole in it not a sexual routing
from the word narcissist loving yourself
means you are only sexually attracted to
yourself Wow Wow
okay I would say yes big time that's a
big time point Jenna I was like that I
imagine these are like English class
notes but you're texting right now I
know it looks like you're big I'm saving
it for later to check on a study there's
pre clap ulation pre clap uation
okay Oh pre clap ulation
markers maybe someones weird fetish that
we're finally like making their day okay
what's your definition pre clap ulation
when you high-five yourself or give
yourself around to applause before you
ejaculate paints a picture creates a
visual can I say I'm a painter I say
when you clap before the rest of the
audience does it happens to a lot of
audience members repopulation means
clapping before you even know what
you're clapping for Oh grace that's a
point for you though there's this close
I was gonna say clapping before you even
know you're clapping for could also work
in your death what there was a close on
what we're gonna get that one guys
all right it's what is the score three
two - three two - okay let's do this the
next word is kids seseri Oh can't seseri
get weird okay done
I said kids with kid leash backpacks and
or a kid you should leave at home before
going out they take one accessory off
before you go out and work it off I'd
say the same thing when you wear your
kid on a leash like a handbag yeah okay
it's a child head by a celebrity just
for the attention usually given a
bizarre name because who cares are the
child has to go through growing
they're just a kids necessary okay I
don't know do we both get a point for
that feel like yeah that's pretty close
okay it's four to three
something about four three all right go
time so Jenna just needs one more point
dance ready Oh whoopsie wave excuse me
Oh whoopsie waves spell it for here no I
just created a visual I nailed it okay
where do you go I nailed it when you
throw your whoopee cushion in the ocean
and a whale sits on it lol mine's kind
of close to that mine is the ripple
effect from a body of water and or
bathtub when you accidentally fart when
you wave to someone you know another
person intercepts your wave mistakenly
as if you're awaiting to them you caught
in the crossfire of the wave look see
whale whoops you it makes so much sense
neither one of us get a next word it's
actually a phrase I feel like it needs
to be said with a little bit of attitude
monotone Jack Barry you don't pour my
cereal okay got it done Dan yeah what
someone with no arms says when they want
you to go away feel like that would get
the point across
Emily God you don't pour my cereal uh
when your eight-year-old self wants to
remind your mom whose house this
according to urban dictionary I feel
like the definition also needs to be
read with a little advance please
regalis you don't know me you don't know
what I do you ever live my life you
don't know my struggles nor trials and
tribulations
[Laughter]
like Jenna was really close to give her
the point that's fine no one pours Jenna
theory oh yeah nice you let me win
don't pour my barrel I love it we've
learned so much and we're gonna learn
more after we record the podcast so make
sure you guys go to iTunes and
SoundCloud and listen to the full
episode of the podcast and Jenna where
if they don't know can people find you
on the Internet jenna Marbles on youtube
do the marbles on everything else with
like an underscore in institution also
gennaker marbles on xbox if you want to
play all their scrolls with me I can't
wait to get into more conversation about
elder scrolls on this podcast right now
because I am forever curious thanks for
watching guys see you next time I don't
know most satisfying bowl of food to
plunge your fist into I'd say spaghetti
and meatballs yes I want that I'm gonna
dip my fists right dip them and smash
them together and then touch them and
then high-five myself then eat it off of
hands
[Music]